村田製作所チアーリーディングです
の僕は
不安定なボールの上でバランスをとることができます
さらに従来のロボットで4名称なんすができることを特徴としています
このロボットは世界中の人々に元気を与えそして笑顔を届けるために開発されました
私はそのプロジェクトリーダーを担当しました
このプロジェクトは今から3年前に発足したものなんですが実は私このプロジェクトに
否定的でした
なぜかを説明します
こちらに写っているのが我々が発表してきたロボットたちです
1991年圧電振動ジャイロを紹介するロボットとして初代村田製作を発表しました
そして bluetooth モジュールや
mems センサーなど最新の技術を搭載し
2005年に二代目村田製作も発表しました
そして2輪車から12社方へと大きな進化を止めた
ムラタセイコちゃんは2008年の誕生です
いずれも電子部品の可能性や精度の高さを紹介するためのロボットとして発表してい
ます
当時
私の星からですね新しいロボットを開発せよという指示が下りてきました
しかしわたしそれを反対しました
なぜかというと
当時のムラタセイサク君は年間250回を超える出張をこなしており人気の衰えを全く
感じていませんでした
さらに
私どもが発表する新商品は携帯スマホで使われるような超小型超薄型の部品を開発して
おり
ロボットの進化とは何ら関係のないこういう理由によるものです
しかし私のボスは納得しません
そこで私は社内でアイディアコンテストを募り
アイディアを出すことにしました
このようにいろんなアイディアが集まってきました
例えば水中を走る凸凹の坂を上る
丸太の上を走るいろんなアイディアが出ましたがわたしの心には響きません
なぜかというとこのロボットの進化は何がしたいのか
そのメッセージがないからなんです
そこで私とボスさらにその役員を交えて議論しました
当時のホワイトボードの様子ですいろんなキーワードが散り散りばめられていますが私
の中には一つだけ引っかかる言葉がありました
それはコンセプトカーというものです
今年も東京でモーターショーが開かれました
自動車メーカーが技術の動向や
将来をプロダクトとして紹介しているものが
コンセプトカーですそうだこういうロボットをつくって未来を見せる
こういうことに置き換えればいいんだ
これは私の中での what から why の転換です
強いが決まるとコンセプトが決まります
じゃあ2輪から1厘じゃ次は02に進化しを
0厘要は球体じゃない
じゃあ次は1台ではなくっていろんなモノをネットワークでつないでいこう
軍で動くロボットを作ってみようこういうアイディアがどんどん出てきました
そして
コンセプトカーである未来の車というのは私
車好きでもある私にとっては大変ワクワクする存在でもあります
今回新しく作るロボットもワクワクするものにしよう
そして作る人からもワクワクしたようなプロジェクトにしたい
そういうふうにプロジェクトを走らせてきました当時のプロジェクトの要素をご覧
下さい
こちらは
ほぼ完成している時の様子です
今から
プレこのムービーを撮影しているときの様子です
緊張した様子でロボットを見守る開発のメンバーたち
映像は変わりましてこれは京都大学で開発している時の様子です
ボディにはまだ衣装を着けておらず白いボディむき出しの状態です
のザリオ冷え
これが6台初めてシンクロして動いた時の様子です
場所が変わりましてこれは滋賀県にある研究はい開発をしているところの職場です
ゴールに乗りながら移動するというのがどれだけ難しいか
画像を見てもお分かりいただけると思います
倒れた原因を一つ一つつぶしていきながら走れる距離を伸ばしていきました
こちらは社内でのお披露目会の様子です
関係者を集めてここまで出来たよという報告を行いました
ん
発表の1カ月前がこのような状況です
ここで開発したメンバーのインタビューん
たい事をやらせても
安謝困ってたり
再びへムービーの撮影状況に戻ってきました
ん
体がで使うような高額な機材の麻耶子
皆さん緊張した面持ちで撮影に臨んでいます
このムービー
2分ぐらいのムービーなんですけども撮影に3日かかりました
この時補助輪も外して本気でモードで望んでいる時
6時に終わって開発メンバーのファンドの様子がわかっていただけると思います
このような村田政策集チアリーディングには3つの技術を搭載しています
それぞれ頭文字を取って3 s と呼んでいます
まず1つめの s はスタビリティ不安定なボールの上でバランスをとるための倒立
親子制御技術というものです
体の中に登載されたジャイロセンサーを使って体の指定情報を瞬時に取得しバランスを
保ちます
このジャイロセンサーというのは身近なところではデジカメの手ブレ防止機能の中で
使われているほか最近では自動車のして横滑り防止装置にも使われ自動車のし精製業
姿勢安定安全性を起用する技術として今後ますます活躍の場を広げています
2つメネスはシンクロナイゼーション
複数台のロボットが強調して動作するための軍制御技術というものです
これは京都大学末の研究室と共同で開発した技術です
3つ目の s は線シンガーのコミュニケーション
超音波を利用した1ケース部技術というものです
屋外で一応する術としては gps というものがあります
人工衛星から降り注ぐ電波を利用して自分の位置を特定するものですもうカー
ナビゲーションで皆さんお馴染みですよね
ところが二チアリーディング部は室内で動作しますのでこの電波が取得できません
よってこのステージの後ろに
立っている2本のポールこの先端をその子の先端から超音波と赤外線を一定周期で発信
し
その音と光の速度差を利用して一応
センシングします
センシングした位置情報は無線通信を使ってシェアします
シェアすることで自分の周りに誰がいるぶつからないようにするにはどういうルートを
たどればよい
これがわかるようになります
こういうセンシング&コミュニケーション技術というのは例えば
災害現場におけるレスキューロボットでの適用は記載されています
このように災害現場で人をいち早く発見しなくてはいけない
こういう探索ロボットがいます
探索をするためには小型のロボットが2は良いです
がれきの下が簡単に入りますから
しかし小型ゆえのハンディもあります
例えば大きなギャップに出くわしたときそれを乗り越えることができません
この時複数台のロボットが強調して周りにあるがれきを集め橋を作ってその上を走破
する
このようなことが可能となります
このように
村田製作所チアーリーディングの中には様々な技術が入っておりこの技術はやがて我々
の生活の中に入ってくる技術です
このチアリーディング部を通じてみなさんが思い描く未来のイメージをぜひ
思っていただければ幸いです
今回このプロジェクトの中で私は
終わったよりも why が重要であるということを再認識しました
今日このプレゼンテーションを聞いて頂いた皆様も何か一つでも気づきを持って帰って
いただけたら幸いに思います
最後にテックス用のフォーメーション特殊なフォーメーションを用意しましたので最後
にこのビデオをご覧下さい
ん
me
持っています
n 君は
tan
me
ありがとうございました